some years ago I was visiting Paris and
walking along the Seine River during a
beautiful summer afternoon I saw giant
bubbles floating on the riverbank like
this one the next moment it pops and
work on making them were tall street
performers surrounded by a crowd they
visibly make a living by asking for
donations and by selling pair of sticks
tie with two strings when I was there a
man bought a pair of sticks for 10 euro
which surprised me I am a scientist who
is passion about bubbles I know the
right tricks to make the giant bubbles
is the right soapy water mixture itself
not in the stakes which may be needed
but you can easily make it at home
focusing on the six makers not see that
the real tools is the bubbles itself
bubbles might seem something just
children make well plain but sometimes
it can be really stunning however they
are more fascinating science - bubbles
such as a problem-solving tools so I
would like to share with you a few
stories about the science of creating
bubbles and the science of eliminating
the microscopic one since is up on the
screen
let's start with the soap bubble it is
made from a very common substances a
water so in the right mixture you can
see soap bubbles constantly changing
their colors this is due to the
interaction with light at various
directions and the changes of their
thickness
one of the common substance water
molecule is formed by two atom of
hydrogen and one atom of oxygen h2o
on most surfaces water droplets tends to
curve inwards forming a semi hemisphere
shape this is because the water droplet
surface is like an elastic sheet the
water molecule on the surface constantly
been pull inwards by the molecule at the
center and the quality of the elasticity
is what we call surface tension now by
adding so what happened is the soap
molecule reduce the surface tension of
water make it more elastic and easier to
form bubbles you can think of bubble as
a mathematical problem server you say
relentlessly trying to achieve geometry
/ fractions for instant a sphere if the
shape with going leaves the face area
for a given volume that's why a single
bubble is always in a shape of a sphere
let me show you check it out
this is a single bubbles when two
bubbles touch each other they can save
materials by sharing a common wall when
more and more bubbles are added together
they are geometry changes these four
bubbles are added together they meet one
point at the center
when six bubbles are added together a
magical cubes appear at the center
[Music]
that is surface tension at work trying
to find the most effective geometry
arrangement now let me give you another
examples
this is a very simple probes this is
made from two layer of plastic with four
pins connect to each other
imagine these four pins represent four
cities that are equally apart and we
would like to make roads to connect
these four city my question is what is
the shortest length to connect this for
city let's find out the answer by
dipping it into the soapy water remember
the soap bubble film will always try to
minimize the surface area with a perfect
geometry arrangement so the solution
might not be something you expected the
shortest length to connect these four
cities is 2.73 times the distance
between these two city
now you've got the ideas the soap bubble
firm were always trying to minimize the
surface area with a perfect geometry
arrangement now let us look at bubbles
in another perspective my daughter
Zoey loves Festing Zeus her favorite
sports is penguin cause at Mizzou in
southern England where she could see
penguin stream at speed under the water
one day she noticed that the body of
penguin leaves a trail of bubbles when
they swim and asked why animals and
birds like penguin that spend a lot of
their time under the water have evolved
an ingenious way of utilizing the
capability of bubbles the reduced
density of water emperor penguin thought
to be able to dive a few hundred meters
below the sea surface they are thought
to store the air under their feather
before they dive and then progressively
release it as a cloud of bubbles this
reduce the density of water surrounding
them make them easier to swim true and
speed up their swimming speed at least
40% this feature has been noticed by the
ship manufacturer I'm talking other
about the big ship here the one that
used to transport thousands of container
across the ocean recently they develop a
system called a lubricating system
inspired by the Penguins in this system
they produce a lot of air bubbles and
redistribute across the whole of the
ships not an air carpet that reduce the
watery system when a ship is moving this
feature cut off the energy consumptions
for the ship
to 15% bubbles can also use for
medicines because you can play a role in
medicines for instance as a method for
non-invasive delivery system for drugs
and genes to a specific part of a body
imagine a micro bubbles fill with a
mixture of drugs and magnetic agents
being injected into our bloodstream the
bubbles will move to the target areas
but how do they know where to go because
we place the magnet there for instant
this part of my head when the micro
bubbles move to this part of my hand we
can pop it via ultrasounds and release
the drugs exactly where it's needed now
I mentioned about the science of
creating bubbles but sometimes we also
need to remove them that's actually part
of my job my job title is ink
formulation scientists but I don't work
on the ink that you use for your
fighting pens I'm working on some cool
applications such as organic
photovoltaic or PV and oh can i light
emitting diodes or LEDs of my job is to
figure out how and why we want to remove
the bubbles from the ink that my company
produce during the formulation mixing
process or preparation process we makes
active ingredients solvents and
additives in order to achieve the
formulations with the properties we won
when the ink is being used but just like
you make a drink or bake a cake it is
unavoidable that some air bubbles will
be trapped inside those in here we are
talking about different space from the
bubbles that I've seen in Paris
the bubbles that trap inside those ins
varies between a few million adults a
few microns or even a few nanometers in
size and what we are concerned about is
the oxygen and the moisture that traps
inside at this size scale removing them
are not easy but it matters for instance
for organic light-emitting diodes seems
yeah we can use to produce display for
you my smartphone for examples it's
supposed to last for many years but if
the ink that we use have been adult with
oxygen and moisture and are not being
removed then we can quickly see dark
spots appear in the pixels now one
challenges we face in removing the micro
bubbles is is that they are not very
cooperative they like to sit there
bothering in the ink without moving much
but how do we kick them out one
technology we use is the Forester in
going through a thin long and tiny tube
with a porous wall and we place the
tubes inside the vacuum chamber so that
the bubbles can be squeezed up from the
ink and being removed once we managed to
remove the bubbles from the ink that we
produce it is time for celebrations
let's open a bubbling champagne
booth is going to be fun
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you will see a lot of bubbles rushing
out from the champagne bottles these are
the bubbles fill with carbon dioxide a
gas has been produced during the
fermentation process of the wines let me
pour some out I can miss that chance
I guess it's nothing here I can see a
lot of micro bubbles moving from the
bottom of the glass to the top of the
champagnes before it pops image as tiny
droplets of aroma molecules and
intensify the flavour of champagnes make
us enjoy much more the flavour of
champagnes as a scientist who is passion
about bubbles I love to see them I love
to play with them and I love to study
them and also I love to drink dance
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]